En un cuestionario de mate ganas 5 puntos
por cada pregunta que respondes correctamente.
En la tabla de arriba, "q" representa el número
de preguntas que contestas correctamente en
tu cuestionario y "p" representa el número
total de puntos que obtienes en tu cuestionario.
La relación entre estas dos variables puede
ser expresada por la siguiente ecuación:
"p" es igual a "5q" donde "p" son los puntos que obtienes,
y "q" el número de preguntas que contestas correctamente.
Podemos verlo en la tabla, si no contestas
ninguna pregunta correctamente,
entonces tienes 0 puntos, si "q" es igual a 0,
5 por 0 es igual a 0,
si contestas una pregunta correctamente
tienes 1 por 5, 5 puntos.
Dos preguntas correctas tienes 10 puntos,
2 por 5 es igual a 10, 3 por 5 es 15,
así es que está correcta la tabla.
Y luego nos preguntan,
¿cuál de los siguientes enunciados es correcto?
Marca todos los que apliquen.
Pensemos en estos casos.
La variable dependiente es el
número de puntos que obtienes.
Cuando vemos lo que nos están planteando
aquí, el número de puntos que obtienes,
es consecuencia de las preguntas
que contestas correctamente,
aquí no es el caso de que el maestro dijera, por ejemplo,
"tienes 15 puntos, entonces tienes que contestar tres preguntas correctamente".
Es justo al revés, el número de respuestas correctas
es la variable independiente y eso está determinando
el número de puntos que obtienes, así que el número de puntos que obtienes es la variable dependiente.
Usualmente se expresa, a la variable dependiente
como igual a una expresión,
que contiene la variable independiente.
Y eso lo tenemos aquí, "p" depende del valor de "q",
al multiplicar el número de respuestas
correctas por 5 obtienes "p".
La variable dependiente es el número de puntos
que obtienes.
La variable dependiente es el número de preguntas
que contestas correctamente.
No, ya hablamos de eso,
esa es la variable independiente.
La variable independiente es el número de
puntos que obtienes.
No, eso no es correcto, esa es la variable
dependiente.
La variable independiente es el número de
preguntas que contestas correctamente.
Esto es verdad.
Es la que está determinando la variable dependiente.
Y podemos checar nuestra respuesta.